[Music]
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
the show is currently casting roles
filming begins in january 2021
and the show will air in 2022 it's based
on georgia martin's book fire and blood
vol 1
and on mars yet unfinished fire and
blood volume 2 book
mig well sapochnik and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and executive
producers
george r martin will also serve as
executive producer
hbo's spin-off house of the dragon has
also recently announced its first
casting via
entertainment weekly it's confirmed that
english actor patty constandine will
star in the prequel as king viserys the
first targaryen
the man who began the targaryen civil
war known as the dance of the dragons
although he's certainly never meant for
it to come to that
this makes him officially the first
actor cast in the new show
set to land in 2022 the news comes
complete with a casting description
which sounds intriguing by itself king
viserys targaryen is chosen by the lords
of westeros to succeed the old king
jaehaerys targaryen at the great council
at harrenhal
a warm kind and decent man viserys only
wishes to carry forward his
grandfather's legacy but good men
do not necessarily make for great kings
viserys the first targaryen was the 5th
targaryen king to sit on the iron round
ruling from 103ac to 129 ac
he succeeded his grandfather the old
king jaherys the first
viserys continued prosperous peace and
legacy of his grandsire
but the seeds for the civil war known as
the dance of the dragons that would much
later engulf the realm
were inadvertently sown in his reign
viserys was a dragon rider
who rode valerian until the dragon died
of old age
viserys never bonded with another dragon
after valerian's death
indeed king viserys was known as a
decent guy
and ruled westeros during a largely
peaceful time when the targaryen dynasty
was at its height
but the succession crisis after his
death would tear everything apart
to make a very long story short after
viserys dies
there's a bitter battle between his
daughter reiner targaryen
who he had named to be his heir and his
son aegon targaryen rhaenyra's head
brother born of another wife after
rhaenyra's mother had died
this was the dance of the dragons and
it's what house of the dragon will cover
the dance of the dragons was the most
devastating war in the history of the
seven kingdoms
the war of succession between aegon ii
and his half sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first throne
by the end of the reign of king viserys
first targaryen twenty dragons were
alive
the majority of these died during the
civil war called the dance of the
dragons
which began in 129 ac and lasted until
mid 131 ac
entertainment vehicle also confirms some
other role stage beer is currently
casting
princess rhaenyra targaryen king
viserys's chosen heir
a dragon rider who grew up expecting to
become the first ruling queen of
westeros
queen ellis sent hightower iserius's
ambitious second wife
and rhaenyra's stepmother who had three
children of her own with the king
aegon the second targaryen princess
rhaenyra's younger half-brother who
challenges rhaenyra's claim to the
throne
igniting a civil war prince daemon
targaryen
rhaenyra's uncle and experienced warrior
it's now officially confirmed that game
of thrones prequel series house of the
dragon will start with a build up
towards the dance of the dragons
and early seasons will cover the prelude
2 and the actual targaryen civil war
later seasons however will be based on
georgia arms yet unfinished fire and
blood volume 2 book
let me remind you that game of thrones
prequel show is based on the book fire
and blood which has two parts
vol 1 as well as yet unfinished vol 2.
the released fire and blood volume one
book covers the history of house
targaryen
from the targaryen conquest aegon's
conquest of the seven kingdoms saw west
rose to the dying of the dragons
the great civil war known as the dance
of the dragons and its aftermath
the reign of rhaenyra's young son aegon
iii
the yet unreleased fire and blood volume
2 book will continue with the reign of
aegon iii
known as the dragon spain for the last
dragon died
during his reign and will continue with
his sons after him
including the famous dare on the young
dragon a 14 year old alexander the great
figure who conquered otegon the
conqueror
failed to conquer dorne but died in the
process
then it will continue with king balor
the blast and the brief reign of viserys
the second
after that aegon iv known as zagon the
unworthy whose reign is a buildup
towards the blackfyre rebellions when he
legitimized his bastard son daemon
giving him blackfyre surname after he
gave him the famous targaryen sword
blackfyre
when aegon iv dies his targaryen
children have to face a rebellion and
defend the realm from the blackfyres
the final seasons of game of thrones
prequel show could include all of that
and more
robert's rebellion the fall of the great
targaryen dynasty as fire and blood
volume 2 book will cover as well
how do i know the second part of the
targaryen history will cover all of that
because george rr martin himself
revealed it could you give us
an idea of some elements that it will
contain we go up to the reign of aegon
the unlucky here
what are what are the highlights of the
putative next volume of this
well i mean i i i
this book only goes up to the regency of
aegon and ends when aegon iii
actually reaches man and takes control
so i have his reign to cover
which includes the death of the last
dragons although aegon iii
is called the dragon bane there are
still three or four dragons kicking
around when he takes the crown and there
are none by the time he's over
so that one thing i was going to cover
why and what happens there
and some of the troubles and rebellions
of his reign
and then ultimately his children who are
fairly
interesting i mean he has ultimately
five
um one of whom is there on the first a
young dragon who conquers dorne
and he's a 14 year old alexander the
great kind of
hero king figure but he dies young and
then his
his brother bailor takes over and baylor
is uh very religious very he's more of a
saint louis kind of figure um a little
extreme in his religiosity and among
other things he
he uh imprisons his three sisters in
luxurious imprisonment in the red keep
the maidenvault but he doesn't like them
like walking around
court because they tempt him with you
know they have breasts and things
underneath their clothes and he finds
that
very disturbing to contemplate so he
hides them away so i'll tell their
stories and i'll tell baylor's story
and then after him will we get a brief
a brief reign of viserys
the second um and then
the serious son aegon the fourth egg on
the unworthy takes over and he's a
a very colorful figure himself i
obviously
drew on henry the eighth for him you
know henry viii had six wives
aegon the unworthy had nine mistresses
and they were all exist in my head i
know who they all were and what happened
to each of them and who was
who had their head chopped off and who
uh you know had affairs and who did what
so there's a lot of
cool material that and then you get into
the blackfyre rebellions
which were five i've referred to them
frequently
so i'll get all the details on the
blackfire rebellions and
ultimately we'll get up to the the mad
king and roberts vermillion
and that's where i'll draw it to a close
if the show was only based on fire and
blood volume one book then it would have
few seasons
because the show will only cover the
second part of fire and blood volume one
confirmed by casting news to start with
the build up to the dance of the dragons
and of course the targaryen civil war
itself which means that the show will
only use about 370 pages out of fire and
blood volume 1 book
in comparison the book material game of
thrones show used was 4 000 pages
with the additional summary from george
rr martin about the ending
if this prequel show is going to run 10
or more seasons as many expect
and as hbo and georgia or martin
themselves probably won't just as they
wanted game of thrones
or if at least this show is going to run
as long as game of thrones did
then the show will have to use more than
370 pages of the book material
and will likely cover fire and blood
volume 2 book to what extent though we
do not know for sure
it could go on to cover aegon the third
train and his sons there on the second
reign
a character who was based on alexander
the great thereon conquered what again
the conqueror
failed to conquer dorne it could also go
on to aegon iv train
and cover the blackfyre rebellions as
it's also something fans are eager to
know more of and watch
or it could go all the way to the fall
of the targaryen dynasty
as the book fire and blood vol 2 will
and cover robert's rebellion itself
this makes the show even more mysterious
and leaves us in dark
because we don't have fire and blood
volume 2 nor will it be released anytime
soon with george rr martin currently
focusing on the winds of winter
this will leave us spoiler free for the
later seasons of the house
of the dragon although we don't have
many spoilers going into the show
in the first place really or at least
not from the books
some would think that you could just
read the book fire and blood
to know what will happen in the show
based on that very same book
but that's far from the truth why
because let me remind you that fire and
blood is not
a non-conventional novel its imaginary
history book of house targaryen
written by george r.r martin from the
perspective of archmaester gildane
who wrote it many decades after the
events took place and according to
george r martin himself not very
accurate at that
this is a book of imaginary history
chronicling the
targaryen kings of westeros it provides
a context and a background for
everything that happens in a song of ice
and fire and it's
not actually written by me it's written
by archmaester gildane
of the citadel of old town who's a very
distinguished scholar but also a
somewhat idiosyncratic and crotchety old
man who has strong opinions on the
historical figures he's writing about so
some of his uh
views may creep into the text i don't
vouch for its authenticity the
targaryens were people
because wildfire in blood book was
written by george rr martin
it wasn't written from him as facts but
rather through the perspective of the
citadel's archmaester gildane
who gathered all the info and as many
different sources as he could
and used it to write the book about the
targaryen history
some info is fake some info is true some
info is semi true
no one will know for a fact what was
happening in the real history
until the house of the dragon airs in
it's it's not a conventional novel it is
imaginary history written in the style i
didn't
this is uh this book's not actually
written by me you see it's written by
archmaester gildane of the citadel
and he's writing a history and like
anyone writing history he has to go back
to primary sources
and i had a lot of fun with that because
when he gets to the dance of dragons he
has a number of primary sources but
three of them are most major he has he
has grand master or wilds official court
records
he has the septon who was
kept the the sept in king's landing and
the red keep
who of course is a is a religious figure
so he interprets everything
as the will of the gods and what was a
sin and what wasn't the same
and he has mushroom who was
semi-illiterate
and couldn't actually write anything but
who told his story
um in later years to a to a
equivalent of a monk who wrote it all
down and mushroom story of course is
always the most scandalous
girl-less filthy version of events uh
all of which have to do with people
betraying each other and poisoning each
other and
having similar type fun and sleeping
in places they shouldn't sleep and all
of that
i love the idea since this was a fake
history i didn't want to
tell it as an omniscient historian
setting down this is what actually
happened i love the idea of
telling it as a historian in world who's
trying to figure out what happened but
he's looking better as primary sources
and he's finding contradictory accounts
modern historian or someone like
archbishop gildane
has to sort through these stories
these contradictory stories and decide
which he believes and which he doesn't
believe
and i had a lot of fun being able to
tell you know
mushrooms accounts which are probably
all turned up to 37
and then the dollar accounts but i
didn't have to just stick to the dollar
account so i could give all three
and that was a great deal of fun and
gildane's sort of favorite phrase that
he comes back to is i guess we'll never
know after after presenting every
version of the story
the show unlike the book will contain
truth it will depict what actually
happened
not the change history fake or semi-true
not what might or might not have
happened it's confirmed that the house
of the dragon show will start with
prelude to targaryen civil war
but it is and will be for a long time
unknown to what extent will the show go
many thought the show was going to start
with aegon's conquest
and go to the dance of the dragons
there's roughly the same time difference
between that
and between the dance of the dragons and
the end of the targaryen dynasty that
ended with robert's rebellion
there's a big possibility that in the
final season of the targaryen prequel
series we could see robert's rebellion
and finally get answers to all the
questions we have daenerys being born
and smuggled into exile to escape
robert's wrath could be the final scene
of the house of the dragon show
for the end i just want to share with
you guys that the same swords that sent
me season 7 and 8 leagues
that turn out to be 100 true has
recently sent me leaked outline for the
first season of house of the dragon
i'm not sure if i should share it with
you or not so let me know in the
comments section down below
do you guys want to stay spoiler free
because this does seem to be legit
or do you want me to make videos about
it covering every and each episode
leaked outline of the game of thrones
sprinkles show season 1.
let me know thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed this video
and if you did please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace